so the EU is negotiating a new trade and
investment agreement with the US it's a
big deal in many ways and yes it affects
you that's the whole idea the
transatlantic trade and investment
partnership or ttip would benefit us in
Europe and the rest of the world too it
would mean more choice and better value
for European Shoppers and good news for
business but it wouldn't just be about
bargain hunting or ttip's potential to
boost Europe's economy and secure jobs
into the longterm there'd be shared
benefits as well the deal would help set
new rules for a better fairer global
economy and build an even stronger
partnership with the
us we're listening we do get it learn
more about ttip and have your
[Music]
[Applause]
say